there's new information this morning
about a mysterious deadly shooting at a
popular California State Park Tristan
Beaudette was killed in his tent while
camping with his two young daughters at
Malibu Creek State Park on Friday now
investigators initially said that the 35
year old was shot in the torso the Los
Angeles Times now reports that beau Dutt
was actually shot in the head
CBS News has learned at least five other
shooting incidents happened in the park
area within the last two years Carter
Evans is at the sheriff station in
Calabasas near the State Park Carter
good morning good morning the sheriff is
increasing patrols around here and still
asking for the public's help to track
down this killer meanwhile more people
are coming forward with their own
stories of how they were shot at while
camping nearby
we spoke to one man who wonders if his
case is connected so where were you set
up here um so I was just down right here
James Rogers was sound asleep at his
campsite in November 2016 when a
stinging pain jolted him awake at 3:00
a.m. I tried to get up I just fell right
through the hammock down to the ground
so you had no idea what happened no idea
it wasn't until pellets started falling
out of his right arm that Rogers knew
he'd been shot these are shotgun pellets
yeah it's birdshot so they're a little
bit smaller I think they're like three
millimeter diameter bb's but it shoots
100 of them Rogers campsite was within
about a mile of where Tristan Beaudette
was shot and killed early Friday morning
Beaudette was inside his tent in camping
with his two and four year old daughters
this is where Beaudette was shot and
investigators aren't saying from which
direction the gunfire came but just look
around here there are plenty of places
where a gunman could hide and escape
unseen investigators confirm there have
been three other shootings in the area
two from 2017 and one that happened just
four days before Beaudette was killed I
felt safe here and so I don't feel that
anymore and that's James Rogers
described his case to California state
parks but says they never followed up
with an official report nearly two years
later he doesn't think investigators
ever took him seriously obviously this
latest incident
is just such a tragedy I think that guy
had known if there had been a warning he
probably wouldn't have booked the
campsite for his family California state
parks officials declined to provide any
information about any of the shootings
in the area citing an active
investigation sheriff's detectives still
won't say if they're any closer to
finding the gunman meantime that entire
campground where Beaudette was shot is
closed indefinitely Gail that's probably
a good idea right now thank you very
much Carter